I've definitely had experiences where
it's like teachers could care less about
what's going on you know what that's a
huge misconception because I know like
I'll talk to the students and they'll go
oh sudden misses and such' starts you
know she hates my guts I'm like she
doesn't she speaks highly of you hi I'm
Douglas I'm an English teacher
specifically I teach American literature
and poetry and I'm also poet hi I'm
Chris and I recently graduated high
school
I'm Ainsley and I have been teaching for
eight years and I teach math I'm Miranda
I'm a rising senior and I'm looking
forward to the college process my name
is Arthur I teach algebra and Santa
Monica
my name is Joelle I am a rising senior
in high school and I founded an
organization that focuses on educating
teens on sexual harassment and assault
that's not in their health class it
feels like scores are more important
than learning
I definitely think as a math teacher
data is like extremely important and I
know that when I was teaching in the
Charter system it was to the point that
I think as teachers we would almost be
like pitted against each other based on
like how successful our classes were and
I started to realize that if I didn't
care about the students learning and
their well-being it didn't matter what
they scored because it it was kind of
like the score wasn't always
representative of what the student knew
was his scores of sports everyone is a
human it you can't just put a number to
that person it just doesn't make sense
it's amazing because I can understand
the topic completely but when it comes
time to take the test it's gone it's so
hard to feel like I understand this like
what's wrong with me am i stupid like
why don't I get like I get this one time
a day but then when the other comes
around it's like yeah I mean quiz gonna
save my life it's my life I use Quizlet
I use Khan Academy when I was stressed
out when I was feeling as if I need I
was gonna break down I used it it was a
good resource for me this year I took
the CASP I don't know if you guys it was
the stupidest thing I've ever taken
inside it was like Microsoft like 2008
like and I was just saying they poured
so much time and money into this test
that isn't indicative of anything at the
end of the day they're doing SAT ACM AP
every year and it's just bombarded on
them and it's not even representative
success because how many kids are
spending thousands and thousands of
dollars on prep for that right and then
not everyone has a privilege to afford
that I feel like we feel the same way in
regards to a lot of the you know the
statewide tests and you know the schools
have to stay accredited so they have to
have these certain scores and the
rankings and things like that I also
believe that they don't pay a lot
attention to the achievement gap and we
have like the achievement gap consists
of mostly african-americans students
with special needs now they're focusing
on these different tests to make sure we
have these scores but not putting the
resources in place to make sure those
students are successful as well so
contribute to those scores I work harder
than people think
I have to really think about that I
pretty much worked my ass off for all my
senior year
and I I really wish that my teachers
would actually see that when I had Anna
Simon turn in I would BAM I would do it
right away I agree with that I think
like it's it's not visible the amount of
work that goes on behind it like if I
would like maybe complain talk about
workload of what I had to do it would be
like the response from my parents like
although they're very understanding it's
like I came to this country with like
this amount of money like I work three
jobs and I understand that but we also
need to understand that the college
admissions process has changed
dramatically right like the choices you
make out age like 13 are indicative of
what happens where you go for me like on
a daily basis or school life my day
consists of after school when school is
out I do home instruction for the
district for kids who can't make it to
school I also have like a private
tutoring service then I have a six year
old and a three month year old so then
I'm up to like you know 12:00 1:00 in
the morning just returning emails
talking to parents and when parents call
they want to talk it's like our
conversation so everyone works so hard
and you know people they don't see they
see the fruits of it but they don't see
all the hard work that you put into it
you know I've been using social media to
kind of interact with my students so I
have like Instagram live tutoring for
kids who can't do tutoring after school
but I never realized that open a whole
door of like interactions and like them
reaching out to me that is much harder
than the basic just them coming after
school and then they go home and
literally like in my PJs in tutoring the
math over Instagram life I sense that a
lot of my teachers were just there to
teach and I didn't want to be that
teacher and I think I've put a lot of
pressure on myself to be different but
that's definitely increased my workload
even though my kids don't see that so
our department as an English teacher is
notorious for how much we do so I think
people are always trying to take things
off of my plate and I swear every call I
get from a parent or
email they always preface it I know
you're busy but do you mind and I think
I'm just very visible about how much I'm
running around and whatnot and so they
really understand this is like the first
time that I'm actually hearing like the
teacher side like I couldn't like fully
understand what it'd be like to be on
call 24/7 like that's insane to even
think about it's hard when you're in
school and that's all you know that's
cyclical like every day and this is what
you're gonna do
it's so hard to kind of like step back
to like realize that sometimes this is
unhealthy like you drink kids on
Instagram live seems like a super super
cool like thing like none of my teachers
would do that and I promise but at the
same time it's kind of like I wonder
what that's like for you being kind of
on-call 24/7 and invading student space
sometimes not staying saying that you oh
I'm thinking about doing some cool thing
on snapchat my son was like no let your
students alone
teachers should care about more than
academics I really agree with that I
think something that I have come to
learn is that when I'm working with
students mental health is a huge thing
that I think as teachers we have to take
into consideration especially because I
see it more prevalent like the struggles
you know success is such a relative term
and we have to understand it together
and collectively it's not just like an A
and B a grade doesn't determine that so
I totally agree with that the first time
I actually like got to see a therapist
and I think it's really important to
provide these resources in schools
especially for students of color where
this topic like mental health is a taboo
in homes like the first time I saw a
therapist was because my English teacher
referred me to one and I was able to see
it on campus but that's because I had
the privilege of having one in my school
in the first place I definitely had
experiences where it's like teachers
could care less about what's going on
they don't like to acknowledge the fact
that I'm taking six of their high level
classes and those all come with two to
three hours you know what that's a huge
misconception because I know like a
bunch of teachers they're phenomenal and
they like to really care about the
students but I'll talk to the students
and
Oh Sud missing such a start she know she
hates my guts I'm like she doesn't she
speaks highly of you miss mrs. Sutter
such as gives tons of work for some
reason you know it's not necessarily
about the amount of work but it's also
like that teacher-student relationship
that you were talking about is for me or
at least in my own experiences it's been
such a strong divide I think like the
harsh reality is for some people it's a
job and it's your 10-year and it's this
job security and like your benefits
right all of these other things put
together in at the same time like
students are people too and I felt like
just plain old like no one cared about
me my senior year was just like the most
stressful thing in my entire life
because I was I would say like I was up
to like two am trying to get assignments
done and study for tests and just trying
to pass because I was I would say like
the last two months when I seen you here
I generally thought that I wasn't gonna
graduate and I didn't know how I was
gonna tell my parents that their
youngest kid their baby is not gonna
graduate high school because I know it
would break their hearts
I deal with a lot of anxiety only
because teachers would stack up
assignments after assignments after
assignments and you know they would you
would think that they would realize that
like you said we're people we have life
like we deal with a lot of personal
stuff on a daily basis yeah I know what
you saying I know you saying cuz I came
up the same way you know I didn't I
didn't have a like I got home and it was
more like oh we had to go I'm gas to get
food you know put food in the
refrigerator and things like that so I'm
trying to do my homework on the bus you
know before I didn't make it home
so it was that whole sense as as well
that school wasn't my first priority so
I try to I try to understand that
especially students that our city would
be struggling behind on assignments and
things like that I try to do stuff like
modify or excuse and I'm that teacher
though like I'm real big on making sure
they all have their materials my mother
worked at my school so I could go there
so I'm real big on your parents put in
so much so you the least you can do is
just come in prepared right
so this kid was like he didn't have his
stuff so he wanted to talk to me outside
and I was just going in on him you know
the rules does this he's like mr. brown
my father died yesterday I'm here
because I can't be at home but I wanted
to tell you that I didn't have your
stuff I just we both just broke down and
and it just broke me because it's like
Here I am trying to tell him what's
important for my class and the only
reason why he was there because of how
he felt about me and he knew he would
feel good in my class way better than
being at home and it just taught me so
much
detention is not an effective form of
punishment
I kind of think of a joke about the
breakfast clever so I remember as a
student numerous times being in
detention just feels like I could have
been in the classroom learning I think
it you know takes the student away from
the learning at school we we don't even
do the detention anymore we have like
circles and things like that so there if
there is a problem with a restorative
restorative justice yeah what kind of
like talk the problems out well we can
do next time
lunk to making long story short I was
caught cheating on tests she straight up
just called me out in front of the whole
class and I was so embarrassed but I
feel like the more efficient way she
should have done it is just after class
she should have just been like hey you
know I saw what you did I what you did
was wrong you're gonna get points taking
away from your grade I just want to
understand why you did it she kicked me
out of class like immediately I went
from Honors Chemistry it's a regular
chemistry yeah yeah like right away yeah
it's stupid yeah I just felt like she
had given up on me and that's not
something I feel like teachers should do
what you say really matters and it
really impacts us been hearing how you
would like champion a student or make
sure that they're being heard yeah
that's super important and I think that
word or at least in my experience I've
lacked teachers like that I work with a
lot of freshmen that they struggle with
the most is application
I'll go why you didn't talk to you know
your teacher about this great there's
you know they're scarier like she's mean
I always tell kids at the beginning of
school year your parents trusted me
enough to drop you off here yeah for
seven hours so just like my kid you know
I gotta teach you like my kids so our
relationship is important I love the
fact that you have like a one-on-one
relationship with your students with you
to like I think you guys are being the
issues we are yeah it helps me reflect
on what I've done this year and my
relationship with my students and
usually I only get to do that in my head
so to be able to talk to sharp students
caring students who really care about
like you said the learning environment
has really helped hearing your guys's
perspective moving forward I have a
little bit more insight as to like how
to interact with students and I really
appreciate it and also hearing the
things that you guys said I'm like
really impressed with you guys so thank
you for sharing seriously very
well-spoken
everyone thank you for watching the
episode follow us on Instagram that's
where we have a lot of behind the scenes
and that's where we can submit prompts
and ideas for episodes and stay tuned we
got more episodes right thanks guys
[Music]